das ist wirklich frankenstein like ein
forschungsteam aus der schweiz hat jetzt
das erbgut einer wirklich ganz neuen
künstlichen bakterien art erschaffen
zuvor hatten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler diese lebensform im
computer entworfen charakter fences 2.0
so lautet also der name des weltweit
ersten komplett am computer erzeugt
genoms eines lebewesens wie bitte damit
kommen wir der wahnwitzigen vision ein
gutes stück näher
künstlich maßgeschneiderte lebensformen
zu erschaffen ob das wirklich gut ist
die zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dank verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen in der fachbereich der
synthetischen biologie hat einen großen
traum künstliche lebensformen erschaffen
die maßgeschneidert sind und fest steht
wir sind auf einem guten weg dahin diese
wahnwitzige vision wirklichkeit werden
zu lassen von neun jahren 2010 fing
alles an damals gelang es das erbgut
eines bakteriums eins zu eins
nachzubauen und es dann in lebenden
mikroben einzupflanzen
der zweite entscheidende erfolg bestand
darin das erste synthetische chromosom
einer hefe zu konstruieren das was jetzt
aber einem forschungsteam aus der
schweiz gelangen überragt das alles noch
einmal denn die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben das synthetische
bakterien genommen nicht nur von ihren
natürlichen vorbildern kopiert und
gekürzt sondern es zumindest teilweise
neu entworfen
somit handelt es sich also um das
weltweit erste komplett am computer
erzeugt die genom eines lebewesens der
name charakter s health 2.0 festzuhalten
ist allerdings dass bisher nur das genom
existiert also ein sehr großes dna
molekül der dazugehörige organismus
existiert noch nicht
die genom version basiert auf dem genom
des bakteriums charakter christus das
überall auf der welt im süßwasser
vorkommt es dient der wissenschaft auf
als modellorganismus da es harmlos ist
keine krankheiten verursacht und
mittlerweile schon gut untersucht ist
insgesamt 4000 gene umfasst das
bakterien genommen natürlicherweise
jedoch sind nur 680 gene notwendig damit
dieses bakterien im labor überleben kann
das hat eine frühere studien gezeigt
anders als die bisherigen experimente in
diesem zug
man kopiert das forschungsteam aus der
schweiz das bakterielle genom von carlo
bakri zentrums aber eben nicht eins zu
eins sondern veränderte es mit hilfe
eines computer algorithmus die dna
abfolge des genoms wurde dabei zwar nur
minimal verändert doch die gesamtheit
der veränderung ist enorm mehr als ein
sechstel der 800.000 dna bausteine sind
im künstlichen genom im vergleich zu dem
natürlichen minimal genom verändert dazu
wert christen der an der studie
beteiligt war
in unserem genom ist die abfolge der
dna-bausteine neue und gegenüber der
ursprünglichen abfolge nicht mehr
wiederzuerkennen
die biologische funktion auf ebene der
proteine blatt geht doch dieselbe
insgesamt wurden 236 genommen teilstücke
synthetisiert und wieder zusammengesetzt
eine komplizierte angelegenheit dazu der
beteiligte forscher und bruder von bert
mathias christen nicht immer ist die
synthese dieser teilstücke einfach denn
dna moleküle haben nicht nur die
fähigkeit sich an andere dna moleküle zu
heften
sie können je nach baustein abfolge auch
schlaufen und knoll mit sich selbst
bilden was die herstellung erschweren
oder verunmöglichen kann
am ende entstand so ein komplett
synthetisches bakterien genommen auch
wenn es auf dem genom des süßwasser
bakteriums charakter christus fuß sind
die abweichung zum original so stark
dass diese kreation als eine neue art
betrachtet werden kann das synthetische
erbgut von charaktertests 2.0 ist sogar
offiziell der us datenbank des national
center for biotechnology information
ncbi eingetragen erste tests haben
gezeigt dass das ungeschriebene genom
noch nicht zu 100 prozent perfekt ist
den bisherigen experimenten zufolge sind
nur rund 580 der 680 künstlichen genen
funktionsfähig doch die fachleute sind
optimistisch mit diesem wissen den
algorithmus verbessern zu können so soll
dann bald eine voll funktionsfähige
genom version 3.0 entwickelt werden so
das forschungsteam und nicht nur das die
experten denken groß dazu mathias
christen
auch wenn die derzeitige gnome version
noch nicht perfekt
so zeigt unsere arbeit dennoch das
biologische systeme so einfach aufgebaut
sind dass wir sie in zukunft am computer
nach unseren flächen definieren und
anschließend bauen können heißt also im
klartext dass es wohl nicht mehr lange
zeit dauern wird bis aus einem solchen
genom funktionsfähige bakterielle zellen
hergestellt werden können und diese neue
technologie aus der schweiz ist sehr
effizient und zudem kostengünstig laut
angaben der fachgruppe waren
herstellungskosten von rund 105.000 euro
120 tausend schweizer franken notwendig
das ganze wirkt also ein extrem großes
potenzial für die biotechnologie
denn solche synthetischen genome könnten
dazu beitragen mikroben zu produzieren
die dann wiederum nützliche biomoleküle
erzeugen beispielsweise impfstoffe
vitamine oder medikamente ein großer
pluspunkt die technologie ist nicht nur
auf charakter anwendbar sondern auf alle
mikroorganismen doch klar ist auch dass
diese art von forschung enorm umstritten
ist und viele ethische fragen aufwirft
denn das erschaffen solcher künstlicher
lebensform ist ein erheblicher eingriff
in die evolution und in die natur und
niemand weiß welche langfristigen folgen
dass wir uns alle haben könnte
die große frage die es zu beantworten
gilt lautet wer darf wann und zu welchen
zwecken eine solche technologie anwenden
gibt es unsichtbare tiere spannendes
video von neugier zone also anliegen
anschauen und neugier zone abonnieren
bis dann bleibt kannten